welcome to this video playing I am
Providence with that John Bryant okay
two games i played against them so far
one win one loss and so we get the the
gates variation of the of the way quite
sure did we had this before I have this
problem maybe d 597 hmm I should really
refresh my knowledge of this line it
gets played rather often and I really
feel I don't know it well enough ok so
this f4 move seems this is probably
coming home cannot prevent f4 Bishop g5
I can play but that looks that looks
kind of weird
hmm f4 can I go d5 here maybe it's got
96 I shouldn't forget about that one hmm
okay maybe I have to live with that for
coming what can I do live or die let's
say mf4 h6 f5 it's not really great but
maybe I get some play due to them um
yeah due to white giving up on the e5
square and weaknesses on the King side
k didn't go for that we should have six
Len or maybe it's probably the right
place for this please anyway okay just
completes us some this build up
hmm interesting can i maybe take on see
to stem this possible some kind of
sacrifice for the e4 pawn don't see it
at the moment I should work ok let's
increase the pressure there I'm not very
happy about at five but what can I do so
it's them some technical stuff night see
494 some other tactics d 5 is e 5 coming
so maybe I should go boo should be 50
eyeshadow i can go back here that's also
not a bad idea no don't be six isn't
exactly great anyway wow really ok and
then I day for isn't isn't exactly a
super great move that's that I didn't
still expect before wow that is that
grade why ok oh no I don't see at bishop
FC Cox is six my membership is a rack
now but maybe I get you for something
I'm not quite sure that this is so great
for him
okay this one I hope the air keeping an
eye on e four so anyway if i get my
bishop some are back i'm not in that
terrible shape is f6 the move what is he
doing C to B to C 2 or something okay
I'm trying to get my bishop back into
the game I have got 95 right who are
cool though loosen aiding here you can
just take it whoops whoops okay
I'm not happy about that but not sure
how bad this really is which I'm just
two moves away from being okay his
bishop is also pretty bad okay let's do
this okay wants to go to fire i can
probably take one scopus OG aid is
coming around you with the bishop time
morning yeah so here but can go back to
g8 now now i'm okay i think i can offer
I heard the position is really okay now
it's not that this is entirely am I mean
it is yeah when white should use don't
get me wrong I'm just saying he also has
pawns that he has to worry about so what
is he doing here trying to go around
here with this okay now mean I can just
stay he really has he has absolutely no
idea here maybe I should just do that
passive but it is just a complete draw
and maybe you can take for the beep horn
oops that's possible I should have
played push up everyone that was a
stupid idea I shoot their only the only
idea here and I'd see it one moment too
late ah that's just that's a super
annoying absolutely completely
unnecessary to lose this I just have to
play Bishop f1 resides there this is
just a dead game completely dead this
position
yeah of course it's not very attractive
but anyway yeah i just have to make sure
that i look at this one idea and then
nothing ever happens because it's just a
fortress yeah ok so let's see here and
what happened ok I don't like this
position so much to be honest as I said
it feels like i shouldn know it better
really was kind of it was some a bit
inconvenient but it turned out to be
turned out to be ok ultimately this I
could have played nights is six here
which you did and now Queen g6 we think
we both overlook that after that wide
winds pretty simply yeah no good move
there 26 threatens this this is the
problem Bishop takes check check keep
getting cured yeah I could have done
that oops yeah that was I mean with this
move i'm pretty much saying okay I'm
going for this this passive defense
which is enough it's a draw but maybe I
don't even have to have to do that I can
go here I am and this is not really
doing that much
all right when this is okay it is it is
draw maybe I could have also a blade
yeah this was a maybe I should have done
that I don't know i mean i can't play
actively yeah it's not i can do this
this is also cave check I mean what what
exactly is the point I basically get the
game position with the pawn check and he
can draw because is active but well
that's better yeah I should have never
lost that game really not okay thanks
for watching